hi in this module i'm going to cover the
basics of linear regression
a story of linear regression begins on
january 1 1801
italian astronomer piazzi looked up at
the night sky and discovered something
which he named ceres he didn't know what
it was what's a comet or a planet but he
did make some observations of the
location before it was obscured by the
sun the data he collected looked like
this
at a particular time two numbers which
represent the location of the of series
in the night sky
so now the big question at the time was
when and where was ceres going to be
observed again to emerge from behind the
sun
all the top astronomers at the time went
and tried to analyze this data and
figure out at the answer
so carl frederick gauss famous german
mathematician took piazza's data and
created a model of series orbits and
makes a prediction
this prediction was actually wildly
different from all the other predictions
that other astronomers made but in
december
series was located and gauss's
prediction was by far the most accurate
so now there's an interesting story here
gauss was actually very secretive about
what his method was and in 1805 the
french mathematician legend was actually
the first to publish the method
before accounts could publish in 1809
even though gals had this method back in
1795.
the method here is none other than least
squares linear regression which is the
topic of this module
so here is the framework
so we are given some training data which
consists of a set of examples each
example consists of an input x and
output y so 1 1 2 3
4 3
and we can visualize these examples on a
2d plot here plotting y the output
against x the input so here is 1 1
here is 2 3 and here is 4 3.
so what we want to do is take this data
have a learning algorithm
produce a predictor f
and the predictor in this case is uh
let's say a line
okay and what the predictor allows us to
do is to take new inputs such as this
three here
and send it through and produce an
output
2.71 corresponding to this point on this
line here
and
there are three design decisions that we
need to make to flesh out this framework
first
what are the possible predictors that
the learning algorithm is allowed to
output is it only lines or is it curves
as well this is a question of what is
the hypothesis class
second question how good is a predictor
and the answer is going to be framed in
terms of determining a loss function
that judges each and individual
predictor in the hypothesis class
and finally how do we actually compute
the best predictor there are a lot of
predictors there
and if we even if we have the loss
function how do we go searching for them
and this is going to be the question of
the optimization algorithm
so this is a recipe that we're going to
see over and over again
and it's kind of like a build your own
learning algorithm
uh so we're going to start
with the first question what is a
hypothesis class
so here is that predictor that we were
looking at f of x equals 1 plus 0.75
now it's a five seven x
and that corresponds to this red line
and here's another one here's a purple
predictor which has
uh a intercept of two and a slope of
zero point two and in general you can
consider predictors of the following
form
f of x equals w1 plus w2 of x for
arbitrary w1 which is the intercept and
w2 which is the slope
so now we're going to generalize this
using vector notation
so let's take w 1 and w 2 and pack them
up together
into a vector which we will call w this
is called the weight vector
and we're also going to define a feature
extractor also known as a feature map
fee
so phi is going to take an arbitrary
input x and return the vector one comma
x at least in this case and one comma x
is going to be known as the feature
vector
so now we can simply rewrite this
equation up here in vector notation so
we're going to write f sub w to denote
that this predictor depends on the
weights
of a particular input x is equal to w
dot v of x
and this w dot phi of x which we'll see
over and over again is called the
score okay so here's an example
if you've taken three into this
predictor
then what we're doing is taking the
weight vector
and dotting it with
the feature vector applied to three
and remember the definition of feature
vector is of one comma x so that's one
comma three here and if you take the dot
product one times one plus zero point
five seven times three that gives you
two point seven one
so now finally the hypothesis class is
defined as
the set script f
is in the set of all predictors
f
sub w where w can be arbitrary intercept
in slope w is an arbitrary vector
okay so that defines our hypothesis
class that we're going to be working
with
so now let's turn to the second design
decision how good is a predictor
so let's take our predictor that we're
looking at the red one
and let's look at some training data so
this is the training data that we had
before let's plot
the predictor and the three data points
this one the two three and four three
so intuitively how good is the predictor
is how
good it uh fits the training data and
we're gonna quantify that by measuring
the distance between the prediction and
the target
this difference is called the residual
so we're going to measure the residual
for each of our points
and
we're going to take that into account
so formally we're going to define a loss
function
which is a function of an example x y
and a particular way vector
and that's going to be equal to
the prediction f of
x
minus the target y
so that's the residual here and i'm
going to square it
so that is called the squared loss
so when it's aside you could also take
the absolute value here which gives you
the absolute deviation loss but we're
going to stick with the square laws for
mathematical components
so on these three examples we can
compute the laws so we take 1 1
and the y vector we dot them together
that's the prediction you subtract off
the target
and that
is
and square it and that gives you 0.32
second example
is a
2 3 and the third example is 4 3 each
one gives you a loss function which
corresponds to the square of the length
of these
dashed lines
so now we can define the training loss
of a particular y vector to be
simply the average over the losses so
formally this is going to be a sum
over all the examples
in our training set
so these
and of the loss function of a particular
example with respect to that weight
vector and then finally we're going to
just divide by the number of points in
the training set
so in this example we just average these
three numbers and we get 0.3
okay so that is how we define the
squared loss and the training loss in
terms of the square loss
so
here is a training loss as we had from
the previous slide and we can visualize
this so for every single weight vector
we can stick it in and get out a number
so fortunately w is only two dimensional
here so we can plot this actually so
here is the plot w1 w2 and every point
here gives you a training loss on the
z-axis
so red here denotes high loss
blue here denotes low loss and
so it's natural to
think about how you would find the the
point here with the minimum training
loss and that's captured mathematically
as minimum of a w of train loss
of w so this is the optimization problem
that we want to solve
so now the third question is how do you
compute the best so fortunately we
already have our well-defined goal we
want to find the weight vector that
minimizes the training loss
and we're going to adopt a very simple
strategy called follow your nose okay so
you start at a particular w and then you
sniff around and then you just move in
the direction that seems like it's going
to reduce your loss the most
more mathematically uh we're going to
define the gradient as uh the direction
that increases the training loss the
most and importantly we want to go in
the opposite direction because we want
to decrease the training loss not
increase it
so pictorially what the fall in the nose
strategy or gradient descent is going to
look like is you're going to start at
some w and then you're going to follow
the gradient and you're going to end up
here and then you're going to look
compute the gradient you're going to end
up here and you might bounce around a
bit but hopefully you'll decrease the
loss um on average over time
okay so here's the pseudo code for
gradient descent
so we initialize w to be something let's
say zeros for simplicity
and then we're going to repeat big t
times big t is the number of epochs
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take our old value of the white
vector and we're going to subtract out
some eta which is called the the step
size
um which we'll get into a little bit
later so here's the step size times
the gradient so grad of returning loss
of w so that's called the gradient here
okay so that's it
there's three lines and really only one
line that's of of interest here and
that's all there is uh to gradient uh
descent
okay so
at least at an abstract level so all
that remains to do is to actually
compute the gradient so remember here is
our objective function train loss is the
average over the individual losses which
i've expanded the square loss right now
but gradient descent is actually much
more general than just
square lots or even machine learning
and now we just need to compute the
gradient
and if you remember
uh your calculus here's how you do it so
the gradient with respect to w of the
train loss of w so remember there's a
lot of symbols here but we are
differentiating with respect to w not x
not y not v
and this is going to be equal to the
gradient of this expression this is just
a constant so the gradient can be pushed
inside
and this is a sum the gradient can be
pushed inside of some linearity
so this is a sum over the training set
again
and then so now the interesting thing
happens so here is something squared the
gradient of something squared you bring
down the two and then you have the same
something which is uh
you remember the residual
times the gradient of what's inside here
and what's inside here is w dot phi of x
p of x is a constant y is a constant so
the gradient of that residual is just
phi of x
and so notice that there's something
interesting i want to point out here
which is that the gradient
can be expressed as
the residual times the feature vector
where the residual is the prediction
minus the target
so intuitively you can think about if
the prediction is equal to target then
the gradient is zero so nothing will
happen
and if the prediction is not equal
target then
the gradient will be in the direction
that ascends the prediction away from
the target and remember we're always
minimizing so we're subtracting that off
and which will move the weights in the
right direction
okay so let's walk through the gradient
descent for our example here so here's a
training example
again
here is expression for the gradient that
we just computed on the previous slide
and here is the gradient update where
i've taken the liberty of just
substituting the step size to be just
point one just for simplicity
okay so
we start with w equals 0 0
and then what we're going to do is plug
in 0 0
into this extrane loss expression this
somewhat nasty looking thing
and
that is this this is just simply the
average three examples one over three
here's the first example here's the
second example here's the third example
each example consists of a dot product
the prediction minus target times the
feature vector of that example
so i'll let you go through the details
here but if you do the math you get
minus 4.67 minus 12.67 you multiply by
the step size and you get
this
weight
okay so now the second iteration you're
going to
take this way vector stick it into this
expression all over again you compute a
new gradient and then you
subtract that gradient times 0.1 from
this wave vector and you're going to get
a new wave vector
and then you keep on repeating and
repeating so um after
maybe 200 iterations you're going to end
up with something like this
and something interesting happens if
you're lucky the gradient at the end
will be
zero
so what is zero means so zero
if you subtract out zero you get the
same thing so means that gradient
descent has converged by subtracting off
the gradient you're not going to move
anywhere and as you might as well just
stop and the stopping point is this way
vector one comma
0.57 which is indeed the red classifier
so just to concretize this even more
let's uh do gradient descent in python
okay so i'm going to pull out the
terminal here
um so
in practice you probably wouldn't
implement gradient descent uh from
scratch except for if you're just trying
to learn about brain descent but for
pedagogical purposes uh let me do this
okay
so um
i'm gonna do this in a kind of very bare
bones way
so i'm gonna use
numpy
rather than pi torch or something that
can do gradients for you
first i'm going to define our training
examples as 1
1
2 3 and 4 3.
i believe those are the training
examples let me just double check over
here one one two three four three
okay so now i have to define a feature
vector of x which is remember is one x
this is just a
numpy array
um i'm going to initialize uh the weight
vector with let's call this initial wave
vector
and this is just going to be all zeros
vector of dimension two which is going
to match the dimensionality of phi
okay so now i need to define the
training loss
training loss takes away vector
and i'm going to actually go to the
previous slide here and it's just
basically copying down math and turning
it into code
so this is 1 over
the number of training examples
times the sum
um and the sum is over
for all training examples x y and
training examples
and for each one i'm going to do w
uh dot e of x it's really literally the
same thing minus y
and i'm going to take this expression
the residual and i'm going to square it
okay so let's make this a little bit
bigger
okay so that's the training loss
um okay now i need to take the gradient
so i'm going to cheat a little bit and
just copy that down here and edit it
so the gradient of the training loss is
going to be
2 times the residual
times
e of x
okay so that's it for the training loss
okay so now i'm going to implement
gradient uh descent
so
i'm going to
um
do it this way actually so gradient
descent
like i alluded to before is actually a
general purpose optimization so all it
needs is a function
gradient access to that function an
initial wave vector and it's ready to go
okay so i'm going to
initialize w to the initial wave vector
and then i'm going to let's say eta to
0.1
um for
a number of iterations t
in range of let's just say i know 500
just for fun
um i'm going to
uh
evaluate the function at w
i'm going to evaluate the gradient
um and i'm just going to do the one line
thing of
subtracting out a to times the gradient
from the existing wave vector and
setting it to the new way vector
and i'm going to print out
where i am so f of t
w equals w
f of w equals uh the value
and let's do the gradient just one so
grad
gradient f
equals um the gradient
okay
okay so now i just need to call gradient
descent
with
what function am i optimizing the train
loss
the gradient of the train loss
is the gradient of the train loss and
the initial weight vector
okay
so
uh that's all i have and let's actually
just
you know run it
gradient descent
um
so we see here that in f x 0 the wave
vector
is something
and the function value is something
greater than something and over time
the function value is going to decrease
which is a good sign
the gradient of f is going to start
becoming zero zero
and uh and the weight vectors are now
converging to
one comma zero point five seven as
advertised
so i will declare this program working
let's just kind of summarize what we did
here
so i want to set this up as follows so
here is the optimization problem
which is
how you you have the training example
the future vectors the loss and gradient
and so on and this is kind of a
specification of what the problem we
want to solve is
and then down here
we have the optimization algorithm
and we're going to be doing this a few
times throughout the course drawing kind
of
modules where we can separate the
optimization problem from the
optimization algorithm notice that on
the optimization algorithm again doesn't
depend on anything
relating to
machine learning at all
and the optimization problem doesn't say
anything about how you solve it so it's
decoupling this what from the how i
think is a really important thing
okay so that was gradient descent in
code
and let's summarize now so in summary we
take training data we have a learning
algorithm that produces a predictor that
can produce new predictions on new
inputs
and there are three design decisions or
build your own learning algorithm which
predictors are possible
that is a question of hypothesis class
and we consider linear functions here
where
the function is simply w dot phi of x
with a particular
feature map one comma x
um you could imagine other things we'll
see other things later non-linear uh
features and even neural networks but
it's still the question of what is the
hypothesis class
how good is a predictor
that's a question of what is the loss
function for regression we looked at the
squared loss
later for classification we're going to
look at the hinge loss and the zero one
loss
um but this is orthogonal for neural
networks we can also look at the hinge
locks or the square lots or any of the
losses
and finally
how do we compute the best predictor
this is a question of what is the
optimization algorithm
and for this we introduce gradient
descent which is this lovely uh simple
and very effective algorithm for
optimization
so that concludes this module
you